اعلن حزب الله اللبناني انه نفذ خمسه
هجمات على مواقع عسكريه اسرائيليه قباله
الحدود اللبنانيه وقال الحزب انه سدف على
دفعتين ثكنه شومي وتجمعات للجنود
الاسرائيليين في محيطها وتجمع لضباط وجنود
اسرائيليين في مسلطنه ايفين مناحم وقوه
مشا اسرائيليه في محيط موقع ل المطله
وافاد مراسل الجزيره باطلاق سته صواريخ
باتجاه الجليل الاعلى و2 صاروخا على
مستوطنتي زرعيت وشوه وقد شنت المقاتلات
الاسرائيليه ثلاث غارات على منطقه اللبون
وقصفت المدفعيه الاسرائيليه محيطه عده
بلدات حدوديه ونعى حزب الله اثنين من
مقاتلي قضايا في المواجهات مع القوات
الاسرائيليه نذهب الان الى بلده الممي
جنوبي لبنان مدير مكتب الجزيره مازن
ابراهيم يتابع لنا هذه ال الصوره ويبدو ان
هناك قصفا جديدا مازل
نعم هي غاره ضربت قبل قليل بلده عيت الشعب
هذه التي تشاهدها الان عبد السلام هي عيت
الشعب
شاهدنا صاروخا اطلق من طائره مقاتله حربيه
اسرائيليه باتجاه هذه البلده التي كان لها
نصيب كبير من القصف والاستهداف الاسرائيلي
نتحدث عن استهداف دائم لب عيتا الشعب وهي
متاخمه للحدود يقابلها موقع الراهب
الاسرائيلي وغالبا ما يتم استهدافها بشكل
متواصل وشكل كبير من قبل المقاتلات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه والمسيرات بالاضافه
الى القصر المدفعي هذا الذي شاهدناه الان
هو الدخان المنبعث من اثار الصاروخ الذي
اصاب بلده عيتا الشعب قبل قليل عمليا الذي
يحصل الان هنالك تطورات متسارعه على خط
الحدود اللبنانيه
الجنوبيه العمليات المتواصله التي نفذها
حزب الله استهدفت خمس مواقع عسكريه في
داخل المستوطنات الاسرائيليه نحن لم نعد
نتحدث عن عمليات عند خط الحدود فقط ولكن
في عمق هذه المستوطنات
وفق البيانات المتتاليه فان العمليات
العسكريه امتدت من القطاع الشرقي في لبنان
وصولا الى القطاع الاوسط حيث اقف هنا
تحديدا في القطاع الشرقي تم استهداف
مستوطنه المطله وايضا استهداف
لمستوطنين نتحدث عن موقعين عسكريين في
المستوطنين بالاضافه الى استهداف مستوطنه
شومي في القطاع الاوسط وايضا استهداف
لمستوطنين نحو تجمع
للقوات قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
مستوطنه ايفن مناحم عمليا كل هذه التطورات
كانت متسارعه خلال الساعات القليله ال
الماضيه نشهد منذ ساعات الصباح اطلاق
صواريخ بشكل كبير من قبل القوات من قبل
حزب الله ومقاومين حزب الله هنا في جنوب
لبنان رصدنا عشرات الصواريخ على طول هذا
الخط البدايه كانت عند نحو الساعه الثامنه
ن30 بالتوقيت المحلي عندما تم اطلاق اكثر
من 20 صاروخا باتجاه اربع مستوطنات في
القطاع الاوس مقابل القطاع الاوسط لجنوب
لبنان وتطور الامر حيث رصدنا اطلاق صواريخ
اضافيه من القطاع الشرقي والقطاع الاوسط
اتجاه مستوطنات في اصبع الجليل وبالتالي
التطورات متسارعه وشاهدنا قبل قليل عبد
السلام هذه الغاره بالاضافه الى مجموعه من
الغارات في منطقه اللبونه وغيرها وقصف
مدفعي لعدد كبير من البلدات اللبنانيه
مدير مكتب الجزيره في لبنان مازن ابراهيم
شكرا جزيلا لك نذهب الان الى الجليل
الاعلى مراسله الجزيره فاطمه خمايسي ربما
توضح لنا الصوره من
هناك نعم يعني لازال التوتر على حاله هنا
في الجبهه الشماليه نتحدث عن دوي صفارات
الانذار في المره الاخيره قبل نحو ساعه من
الان كانت قد دوت في تحديدا في بلده
المناره في الجليل الاعلى ولكن لم يتم
الافصاح او عن وجود اصابات او عن سقوط
صواريخ في تلك المنطقه وحتى هذه اللحظه لم
يتم نشر اي معلومات اكثر عن هذا الحدث
هنالك يعني تعتيم اعلامي كبير تشهده
الجبهه الشماليه منذ بدء هذه الحرب
وتحديدا في الساعات اليوم نواجه يعني
معلومات شحيحه جدا هنالك اختصار فقط على
البيانات التي يصدرها الجيش الاسرائيلي
والتي باتت متكرره وعمليا تقتصر على
الغارات التي ينفذها الطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي في اطراف البلدات الحدوديه
اللبنانيه وايضا عن قصف مدفعي يسمع اصوات
الانفجارات بين الحين والاخر باتجاه
البلدات الحدوديه اللبنانيه هذا هو المشهد
يعني هنا في الجبهه الشماليه ايضا نتحدث
عن وقوع صواريخ في مناطق مفتوحه لم يتم
فيها تفعيل صفارات الانذار وعلى ما يبدو
ان هنالك مناطق يتم استهدافها بشكل متكرر
لكن صفارات الانذار لا تدوي وهذا الامر
مرجح بسبب سقوط هذه الصواريخ في مناطق
مفتوحه ايضا كان هناك صاروخ اطلق باتجاه
بلده مدينه نهريه والتي تبعد اكثر من 20 م
م من الحدود لبنانيه سقط هذا الصاروخ في
البحر وبالتالي لم يتم تفعيل صفارات
الانذار لمنع دب حاله الهلع في صفوف
الاسرائيليين خاصه وان هذه المنطقه هي
منطقه ابعد وفي نطاق اوسع لذلك هذه بمثابه
رساله يرسلها حزب الله الى الجانب
الاسرائيلي وعلى ما يبدو من كيفيه تعامل
وتعاطي الاعلام الاسرائيلي مع هذه الجبهه
الشماليه هنالك منحنى الا وهو عدم تصدير
ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يخوض حرب ويخوض
مواجهه مباشره وواسعه النطاق مع ناصر حزب
الله وان هذه الجبهه يعني تبقى في اطار
الجبهه الدفاعيه بمعنى انها الجيش
الاسرائيلي وعملياته تقتصر على استهداف
مصادر اطلاق الصواريخ في الاراضي
اللبنانيه وليس ان هنالك عمليات استباقيه
واسعه المدى يشنها الجيش الاسرائيلي طبعا
كان هنالك بعض العمليات الاستباقيه التي
شنها في الايام الاخيره سلاح الجو
الاسرائيلي بناء على معلومات استخباراتيه
وعلى رصد عناصر رصد حركه لعناصر حزب الله
في المناطق الحدوديه ولكن بغالب العمليات
هنالك رد فعل اسرائيلي مباشر ومتسارع جراء
عمليات القصف الصاروخي الصادره من جنوب
لبنان فاطمه خمايسي مراسله الجزيره من
الجليل الاعلى شكرا جزيلا
لك